اذا كنت تتساءل عما اذا كان الوقت يختلف
في الارض عن الفضاء فالاجابه التي توصل
اليها العلماء هي نعم فبحسب النظريه
النسبيه للعالم البرت اينشتاين فان هنالك
اختلافا في سريان الزمن بين الارض والفضاء
بسبب تاثيرات الجاذبيه والسرعه النسبيه
لكن مع هذا الاختلاف هل يتغير عمر الانسان
في الفضاء
نظريه تمدد الزمن او الابطاء الزمني تؤكد
ان الزمن في الفضاء ابطا مما هو على الارض
لذا يعود رواد الفضائل الارض ليكونوا اصغر
سنا مما كان يفترض ان يكونوا عليه لو انظر
مده التي قضوها في الفضاء على الارض ما
يعني ان الوقت الذي مر عليهم في الفضاء
كان اقل من الوقت الذي مضى على الارض
بفتره يتم قياسها بحسب السرعه التي كانوا
يتحركون بها في الفضاء